hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today I'm
gonna explain a 1971 British fantasy and
thriller movie called blood from the
mummy's tomb
the movie begins with an Egyptian queen
named Tara who seems still alive but is
peralsied at the moment at the same time
a group of priests commences a secret
ritual and subsequently chops her hand
off
they then throw the Queen's hand away to
the jackals however just before they
Devour the hand the animals begin to
collapse with their throats cut open
while the hand with a huge ruby ring on
it is crawling away the priests
eventually finished the ritual and
shortly after they leave the tomb a
giant Sandstorm strikes killing everyone
instantly in the present day a young
woman named Margaret awakens from his
recurring nightmare her scream alerts
the father Professor Julian Fuchs who
immediately comes to a room and calms
her down she claims to her father that
she keeps experiencing the same dream of
Queen Tara every night the father is
actually a renowned egyptologist in the
country unbeknownst to them a mysterious
man named korbeck secretly observes them
from a distance the next day Professor
Fuchs surprises Margaret with a very
beautiful ruby ring as her early
birthday gift
she puts on the ring right away and then
leaves with his boyfriend Todd Browning
while korbeck is still spying on them
upon arriving at Todd's place he
immediately notices the giant ring and
is pretty Amazed by it Todd learns that
she got the ring from her father and
concludes that it must be retrieved from
his previous Expedition curious about
the Ring's origin the couple meet Todd's
colleague Jeffrey who is an expert in
ancient relics when he takes a closer
look at the ring he suddenly becomes
terrified and suffers a panic attack
especially when he sees Margaret's face
on the ground a kind of weird
constellation appears inside the Ruby
meanwhile a fortune teller named Helen
Dickerson also sees the same
constellation and becomes panicked
suddenly suggesting her client to resume
the session next week on the other hand
korbeck pays a visit to a man named
Berrigan who is currently treated in a
mental hospital or more like a mental
jail it seems like korbeck is looking
for something but Berrigan tries to stop
him from taking the Relic a guard that
intervenes and restrains the man while
telling korbeck to leave at once
a few moments later after calming
himself Jeffrey quickly heads over to
his workplace and takes out a box that
contains one of the Jackal skull shortly
after korbeck arrives and Jeffrey
reports to him that he has found the
ring in the woman
korbeck tells him to be ready as
Margaret's birthday is in a few hours
still that night Margaret who slept in
her boyfriend's house dreams of Tara who
states that her spirit has never rested
and implicitly reveals that her
Resurrection time is getting closer and
closer she continues that she
deliberately guided a group of
archaeologists whom she appointed as
Guardians Of Her Sacred relics to find
her tomb a long time ago the
archaeologists consisting of the young
Professor Fuchs Todd corbeck Berrigan
and Helen discovered the Queen's ancient
relics in a coffin containing Queen
terra's well-preserved body they also
found the Queen's severed hand and
decided to take all the stuff by the
time the archaeologists found the body
Professor fuke's wife gave birth to
Margaret but her life couldn't be saved
back to the present time Margaret
awakens and senses that something is not
right thus she puts on her clothes and
decides to go home meanwhile Professor
Fuchs goes to the basement where he made
the replica of the Tomb and keeps the
Queen's body inside it the couple arrive
at Margaret's house and suddenly hear
screaming they break into the basement
finding Fuchs severely wounded on the
neck Todd immediately calls Fuchs
personal doctor Margaret suggests they
call the police but the doctor doesn't
allow her to do so saying that it is her
father's instruction while Fuchs is
resting Margaret silently returns to the
basement and is very shocked when she
discovers the Queen's body and realizes
that Tara looks almost exactly like her
not long after korbeck appears out of
nowhere and introduces himself to
Margaret he explains that her father was
obsessed with the Terra queen of
Darkness since he was young impressed
with her father's dedication in the
egyptology world korbeck helped him by
assembling a team to search the tomb he
is still amazed by how coincidentally
Margaret was born in the Queen's image
and on the same day when his father
discovered the Queen's body
korbeck believes that Tara's power is
astral and dangerous thus they must find
a way to reunite Terror with her soul
before it's too late he then orders
Margaret and Todd to reassemble the
Expedition team members hoping that they
can gather all the relics that are kept
by the other archaeologists as their
first step Todd calls Jeffrey but he
immediately hangs up the phone
the couple then head over to the mental
hospital to talk to barragon however the
old man is super horrified when he sees
Margaret thinking that she is Tara who
comes to kill her Margaret uses this
opportunity to pretend to be the queen
and questions him where he keeps the
snake artifact Bergen denies that it's
in his possession so she scares him with
a ruby ring as expected barragon begins
to scream in fear attracting the guard's
attention
they restrain the old man and tell the
couple to leave just after they leave
the room a guard takes out the snake
Relic and scares him with it before they
go the guard puts the Relic near him
that night Bergen suffers a panic attack
again when he finds out that the snake
Relic is missing the window suddenly
burst open followed by a strong Rush of
wind wrecking Havoc the whole room
Bergen repeatedly asks for help but to
no avail the wind eventually stops and
unfortunately Bergen lies dead on the
floor with his throat cut off
back at home the doctor tells Margaret
that he finds a slight sign of Paralysis
on his father's left hand side
the next morning Margaret descends to
the basement and discovers that the
snake Relic is somehow retrieved
Fuchs finally awakens from his coma and
reveals to his daughter that he
deliberately gave her the ring for
protection he later explains that the
priest said Tara's era cut her hand off
to symbolize that she was evil also
believing that with her body incomplete
her power would be destroyed thinking
that her father is still hiding
something Margaret informs him that
Bergen is dead and she has been working
with korbeck to solve this problem the
professor becomes worried and tells her
daughter to stay away from korbeck she
ignores him and soon visits corbeck's
house realizing that she might possess
the power of the queen she teams up with
korbeck to resurrect the queen he agrees
as he believes that Tara is beyond
humans laws and Dogma so he is very
eager to learn from her especially about
immortality before she departs korbeck
warns Margaret not to involve her father
because the professor still believes
that the queen is the root of evil not
seeing her as an opportunity to take
control over everything on the other
hand Jeffrey is told about beringen's
death
he immediately realizes that he's in
danger and attempts to hide the skull
however Margaret suddenly shows up
ordering him to hand over the Relic
Jeffrey refuses and tries to escape
through the stairs but he accidentally
kicks the box and loses the skull while
searching for it he suddenly hears a
loud howl of the Jackal and decides to
hide meanwhile Margaret comes across
Todd while leaving Jeffrey's place he
seems confused and becomes suspicious of
her but she Dodges all the questions and
quickly leaves Todd enters the place
searching for Jeffrey all over the
building until he finds Jeffrey's dead
body again with his throat slid off
while carrying Jeffrey's body away he
spots a glimpse of a jackal shadow
meanwhile at the basement korbeck and
Margaret realize that the Relic will
magically return to the tomb as soon as
the person holding it dies a few moments
later Todd confronts them and urges
Margaret to stop however his girlfriend
has been obsessed with the Queen's power
and refuses to withdraw her plan Todd
attempts to seek help and Margaret warns
him that he'll be dead if he leaves on
his way Todd crashes his car and dies
with his throat full of blood Margaret
regrets her decision of wishing Todd
death and eventually collapses Professor
fuke suddenly appears and argues with
korbeck who already knows that Margaret
will eventually die soon after the
Queen's rebirth the professor is
dedicated to making sure that will not
happen
he takes his daughter to his room and
tells the doctor to anesthetize her
however just before he manages to do it
Margaret possessed by Tara stands in
front of him and kills him with her
power Margaret finally regains his
Consciousness and screams in shock when
she sees the corpse she then escapes
from the house to retrieve the last
Relic the cat not long after Margaret
arrives at Helen's place and politely
asks for the cat Relic Helen intends to
eliminate her but later withdraws her
intention after Margaret convinces her
that she will spare her life
unfortunately after she hands Over The
Relic the cat Relic somehow becomes
alive and finishes her off
in the basement Fuchs discovers that the
cat Relic has returned to the Tomb at
the same time Margaret and korbeck
arrive and begin the resurrection ritual
korbeck puts the Queen's hand inside the
tomb and reads the spell from the scroll
halfway through the ritual Margaret
finally realizes that they will be
meaningless once Tara is fully
resurrected therefore with all his
energy remaining Fuchs charges towards
corbeck and stabs him to death however
Tara is revived and manages to prevent
the professor and Margaret from stabbing
her Fuchs is choked to death but
Margaret eventually manages to strike
the knife through the Queen's heart
putting her back to sleep forever after
that the whole basement falls apart
leaving only one Survivor from the scene
the next day a woman whose face is fully
wrapped in bandages awakens in the
hospital
question then arises who are the women
behind the bandages Margaret or Tara
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching